I decided to do example number two first
off we request the page and start
receiving the HTML we start parsing it
immediately and building the Dom we come
across two style sheets style dot CSS
and print dot CSS with the media query
for print we aren't printing so print
dot CSS isn't a part of the critical
rendering path we only have to send out
a request for style that CSS and then we
continue parsing the Dom we run into two
script tags at the end of the body one
for apt ojs and another for analytics
that you asked analytics that jeaious is
async so it's not a part of the critical
rendering path we fire off a request for
app dot j s in halt building the Dom
while we wait for CSS to arrive and the
CSS aam to be built now that we have the
CSS on the JavaScript engine is
unblocked so we can run app KS finish
building the Dom and then render the
page that wasn't too bad